[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
Bolivia en el programa de hoy hablaremos
sobre el incremento de las tensiones
políticas en el país tras la detención
del gobernador de Santa Cruz el opositor
Luis Fernando Camacho escucharemos a las
dos partes por un lado el partido de
Camacho considera que la detención ha
sido un secuestro y que su juicio es un
acto de persecución política en cambio
las víctimas desencata del alto aseguran
que de esta forma se garantiza que no
haya impunidad pues culpan al gobernador
por la violencia sucedida en el 2019
también les mostraremos la fiesta de la
la cita de la paz en la que los
bolivianos compran millones de billetes
falsos además de bienes en miniatura con
la esperanza de que durante el año se
hagan realidad
la detención de Camacho ha ocurrido el
28 de diciembre en un violento operativo
en Santa Cruz luego el gobernador ha
sido enviado a la cárcel de máxima
seguridad de chonchocorro de la paz y
desde entonces la polarización ha ido en
aumento en el país un juez ha decidido
que el Gobernador permanezca cuatro
meses en la cárcel mientras se lo
investiga por el delito de terrorismo
hasta la cárcel de choncho coro situada
en el altiplano de la paz se han
trasladado las tensiones políticas casi
a diario hay manifestaciones que piden
30 años de prisión para el gobernador
que está acusado por el gobierno de Luis
Arce de haber perpetrado un golpe de
estado en 2019 a liderar las protestas
que causaron la renuncia de Evo Morales
pese a estar presencialmente en la paz
las audiencias judiciales para Camacho
son virtuales
pero su detención también ha provocado
manifestaciones que acusan al gobierno
de autoritario en La Paz hubo
enfrentamientos entre quienes apoyan a
Camacho y sus detractores y en Santa
Cruz se produjeron cabildos
multitudinarios el último de ellos
decidió pedir la libertad de todos los
presos políticos y que Camacho siga en
el cargo de Gobernador los cabildos en
Bolivia están reconocidos por la
Constitución como una instancia
deliberativa aunque no de cumplimiento
obligatorio Los Seguidores de Camacho
rechazan la denuncia de terrorismo y
afirman que está preso porque la
justicia ha sido corrompida por el más
para imponer la narrativa de que en 2019
hubo un golpe de estado y no solo
protestas por las denuncias de fraude
electoral contra Evo Morales quieren
negar todos los vestigios del fraude
incluso
han usado descalificar a la oea al
parlamento europeo a todos los que
participaron como bebedores y que ese
fraude y ellos ahora están generando una
narración una narrativa que la han
llevado a la justicia sin ningún otro
elemento más que esta inventiva de
transformarlo el fraude en golpe la
polarización viene desde el año 2016
cuando el expresidente Evo Morales
decidió no acatar los resultados de un
referéndum que le prohibía postular a un
cuarto mandato Pero la crisis estalló en
el 2019 con protestas ciudadanas
denuncias de fraude unas elecciones
fallidas y La Asunción de un gobierno
transitorio al mando de Yanine añez
quien también está presa desde el año
2020 acusada del supuesto golpe
una de las primeras decisiones de añez
fue decretar que las fuerzas armadas
podían reprimir las protestas contra su
gobierno sin tener responsabilidad penal
las operaciones fueron violentas y
causaron la muerte de varios civiles en
la zona central de sacaba y en la andina
desencata
descalificadas como masacres por un
grupo de expertos designado por la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos ese grupo determinó además que
hubo 37 muertos y que el ejército y la
policía usaron una fuerza excesiva y
desproporcionada en sencata murieron
diez personas entre ellas el hermano de
Gloria kisbert un joven de 24 años que
pereció con un tiro en la cabeza
nosotros no vamos a permitir que todas
estas personas quienes nos han atentado
en ese momento queden sin
responsabilidad no que cumplan la
sanción correspondiente por todo lo que
nos han hecho más que toda la gente
humilde la gente amará
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y mientras las tensiones agitan la
política boliviana en la paz se celebra
una fiesta cargada de ilusión y
esperanza se trata de la lacita O feria
de la abundancia en la que la gente sale
a las calles masivamente a comprar
millones de dólares y euros falsos
además de bienes en miniatura esperando
que durante el año se vuelvan realidad
la lacita se extiende por casi un mes y
durante ese tiempo se puede comprar en
versión pequeña todo lo que la
imaginación permita desde casas y
camiones hasta títulos universitarios
desde novios personificados engaños
hasta certificados de matrimonio o de
divorcio Si esa es la necesidad y lo
mejor es que en la festividad participan
todos sin distinción de clases ni
ideologías e incluso mostrando un
sincretismo religioso porque para atraer
la suerte se reclaman bendiciones a los
sacerdotes católicos a los chamanes
aymaras y aleco el Dios Cecilio
abundancia y con el deseo de abundancia
también para ustedes llegamos al final
de clase andino desde Bolivia sigan
nuestra programación en France 24 y
France 24.com